[Music]
hey everyone hi you ready for the last
set of talks oh sure yeah why not cool
them hi I'm Sam I'm also known as snug
UGG throughout the internet this is the
Houdini bunny if you want Houdini bunny
stickers come find me I have a bunch of
them and this talk is available online
at that link
don't worry that link will be up again
at the end of the talk so what is
Houdini for those of you who haven't
been following a web standard that
doesn't really exist in any browsers yet
well the objective of the CSS tag
Houdini task force or CSS Houdini is to
jointly develop features that explain
the magic of styling and layout on the
web
practically though what does that mean
well it means extending CSS via
JavaScript so that authors like us don't
have to wait decades for browsers and
standards bodies to implement new things
but wait you say can't we do that
already and the answer is not quite it's
not currently possible to extend CSS
through JavaScript it's only possible to
mimic job or write JavaScript that
mimics CSS actually polyfill in CSS or
introducing new features like CSS grid
is hard to impossible to do today
especially so without being just
terrible for performance
Houdini will actually let authors tap
into these actual CSS engine finally
letting them extend CSS and do so at CSS
engine speeds I like to think about it
like this much like service workers are
a low-level JavaScript API for the
browser's cache Houdini introduces
low-level JavaScript API is for the
browser's render engines and I think
that's pretty cool so the question that
I always get is can I use it yet and the
answer is unequivocally no no you cannot
use it yet
but I mean maybe kind of things are
coming the web's changing a little bit
so maybe you kind of so normally it's a
warning today it's a heads-up so voodini
is getting pretty stable and you can
kind of start to use it in some browsers
but some of it a lot of it is pretty far
off and landscapes like I said really in
flux most of what we're going to be
talking about today is the mostly stable
bit but you're gonna need to use
polyfills and get your progressive
enhancement on in order to use this
stuff today so let's talk about the core
magical secrets of Houdini the stuff
that you need to understand make
everything else work and the first one
is this thing called worklets worklets
our extension points for render engines
they're kind of like web workers but
they're much smaller in scope they can
be parallelized to live on multiple
threads and most importantly you don't
call them the render engine calls them
they're an extension of the render
engine so this is what adding one looks
like you have a demo worklet and add
module and then a path to whatever your
workload is these are also promises so
you can promise all of them and then off
of them to do work once your worklets
are loaded every worklet has this kind
of shape to it it's got a function that
function is the function that gets
called that function has a name which is
the thing you're actually going to use
in CSS and then there's a class and all
classes will have some sort of process
function which is the actual thing the
render engine is calling whenever it
wants to use your worklet you'll see a
couple examples of this later on let's
take a look at the life cycle of a
worklet we have our render engine our
render engine spins up the main thread
once it's spun up the main thread will
also spin up multiple worklet processes
these work that processes can either be
on the main thread or they can be
parallel to the main thread it doesn't
matter
they're just going to be a bunch of them
sitting around from the main thread
we're going to call our browser
JavaScript and our browser Java scripts
gonna call worklet Add module that's
going to load a worklet and the worklet
will load into two or more work with
processes now here's where things get
interesting and
of our browser JavaScript calling our
worklet the render engine calls our
worklet when it needs to do a render
when it needs to use it
worklets are the underlying foundation
for which all of Houdini is based the
the magic that makes it happen it's what
makes Houdini powerful next bit typed om
the typed om expose the structure beyond
simple strings which is what we have
today for CSS values these can be
manipulated and retrieved really
performant lis and they're part of this
new CSS style value class and there are
buncha turan options there's keyword
values like idents there's position
values transform values unit values and
some math so this is what it looks like
we've got a class of example with a
background position of center bottom 10
pixels now trying to parse that out from
that string is really hard but with the
type 2 m we can get its computed map
sire computed style map and then we can
get background position X and that comes
back as a CSS unit value with a value of
50 and a unit of percentage or %
background position Y it's a sum of 100
percent because that's bottom that's
going to the bottom and then negative 10
pixels because after that bottom 10
pixels bit means in CSS so we know now
no longer need to string parse this and
do disgusting reggae regex
to actually understand what this is we
can just call it and get it typed om
gives us the structure we need to cast
the spells that we want but what can you
do with this you might say well you can
do put some pretty rad things let's talk
about the rad custom stuff that you can
do with worklets and the typed om please
allow me to introduce or reintroduce you
to window dot CSS and the first api
we're going to look at is the properties
and values api aka make the snozzberries
taste like snozzberries so this is kind
of the current state of custom
properties CSS variables we have
something called my color we set it to
green and then we set it to a URL that's
not a color
and everything is sad because urls not a
color and it doesn't know what to do but
then we can do window dot CSS dot
Register property tell it the property
my color has a syntax of color and now
the browser knows it's a color because
the browser knows it's a color that URL
junk is gonna get skipped which is
really nice there are a couple other
things we can do with it we can decide
whether or not inherits up the Dom or we
can also give it an initial value boom
there we go there are a bunch of
different types that you can use the
syntax so you can great lengths you can
create numbers percentages images colors
times resolutions all sorts of different
types for this syntax and you can
combine them so a single item is just a
single item length you can combine them
with a bar separator for an or so in
this case it's an image or a URL if you
have custom idents you can combine a
bunch of them so big bigger and all caps
bigger are three different valid ID ends
if you have a plus that's a space
separated this so in this case the space
separate a list of lengths and then if
you have a hash
it's a comma separated list now now that
a browser actually knows what it is we
can do some pretty interesting things so
we have over here a two buttons styled
with a linear gradient and a custom
property now if I hover over the
unregistered one it does exactly what we
think it does nothing it just pops into
that next color because we can't
transition linear gradients right well
now that we know what a custom property
is now that we know that it's a color if
we transition the custom property then
we can actually do things like
transition linear gradients or
transition anything that is a registered
custom property and that gets really
powerful as you'll see as we go along
but before we do that how can you use
them in your design systems that's the
point of this talk right how can we use
Houdini in design systems
well there is a proposed declarative
syntax for these custom properties that
lets you write these custom properties
not in JavaScript to put in CSS using at
property property name and then the
syntax and it roughly works out to the
JavaScript on the left there on the
right what's nice about this proposed
syntax is you can start using it today
with a post CSS plug in a post CSS
plug-in you write that property syntax
and it will spit out the JavaScript so
you can write all your custom properties
in your CSS deliver them as part of your
design systems as well as the JavaScript
for a fallback which then is
progressively enhanced with the if
statement so some things we can do this
we can make CSS variables smarter so if
we've got our main blue and we have a
property main blue with syntax and
Harrison initial value we can use that
and in fact when the property syntax
ships we can get rid of that initial
main blue call entirely because it'll
just be there available we can also make
things like this background variable
more intelligent by only allowing images
or colors and not allowing it to inherit
up the Dom right now all CSS variables
inherit up the Dom which is not
something you really want for a
background oh it's really cool when we
started to talk about worklets is you
can make truly custom properties so you
can do things like theme colors where
you have identify that you want to allow
you can do things like create custom
columns for layouts you can create your
own padding properties so all these
different actual literal custom
properties as opposed to just
placeholders for things you're going to
put into another property somewhere else
speaking of worklets let's talk about
the paint API because as Bob Rost likes
to say every day is a good day when you
paint yeah Bob Ross have you ever wanted
to use canvas as a background a mask or
a border in CSS with the styling and
flexibility of an element and the
scalability of an SVG of course you
haven't no one has but it turns out if
you can do that it's actually really
cool and you can do a lot of really
interesting things so the paint API the
class for the work that looks a little
bit something like this we have input
properties that's an array of properties
either custom properties or standard
properties you can read standard
properties into that you want to read in
from the element that this is that's
being painted you can also pass input
arguments with that same formatting
syntax as custom properties to pass in
arguments to the paint function and then
the paint function is the thing that
actually gets called it has a 2d drawing
context the size of the element the
properties that get passed in and the
arguments let's write a basic paint
worklet right now so this one's just
going to draw a big circle we're going
to get the circle color property we're
going to get it from within our paint
function and this is actually a CSS
style value this is our type domain in
action then we do some math to figure
out the center point in the radius of
our circle and we draw our circle once
we've drawn our circle we import it and
we get this
I mean I've drawn a big circle in the
middle in the middle of a thing I can
change its color it's nice it's a it's a
cute little circle demo but with this as
our foundation we can do really
interesting things so there's this guy
named Tim Holman and he makes great
generative art so I've converted one of
his generative art demos into an actual
paint background using this so I can
decide how many steps that I want I
start with 50 but if I do 40 and I every
time I reload the page it randomly
generates a new background image for me
I do this with very few lines of CSS I
don't need to load a new image in and
it's all controllable through actual CSS
the worklet isn't so big it's smaller
than loading an image and you can get an
infinite number of randomly generated
backgrounds this way much more
interesting and much more performant
then just loading in a bunch of random
images you can even combine the paint
worklet with that custom property
transition
and you can do something like this and
create a nice little ripple effect by
figuring out where you clicked and then
toggling on a class that has the end
transition state that you want and
transitioning through our paint cool how
can I use this in design systems well
there's a polyfill for it and it works
pretty well anywhere that has canvas and
you're gonna want CSS variables as well
it especially works pretty well in
Firefox and Safari what I think Design
Systems
I think web components or I think
components and when I write components I
think web components I've been using
them recently I really like them and I
think that they're a great way to
encapsulate styling and functionality
and we're gonna use it today to build
our our version of a paint button
although buttons aren't as cool what
we're gonna build so we have this basic
demo of tabs we have a tab you switch
tabs everything switch is hunky-dory
except these tabs have that cute little
rounded corner going out at the bottom
which if you've ever tried to actually
do is not so straightforward especially
if you want it styler Bowl through CSS
and without any extra elements so what
we're gonna do is we're going to write a
paint function a paint worklet that will
write those for us and style it based
off of the background color of our tab
so starting with a web component you
start by writing a template a template
has an ID
it has our styling the styling lives
inside of our template and it's only
going to affect this web component it
won't leak outside we've got a couple
variables up top CSS variables where
we're using a property we're passing in
called tab multiplier to do some math
for us to make sure that our bottom
rounded corners and our top rounded
corners all kind of continue to to be in
sync with each other and then we do some
of the actual a little bit annoying CSS
to get border images working with paint
and then we're good with our styling for
our HTML this is pretty basic
it's a div
and we have this part L or part
attribute on it to allow us to expose
styling outside of our web component
this is part of the new shadow parts
spec for web components the JavaScript
for getting this to actually work and be
usable is very straightforward on the
Left we've got our CSS paint
registrations or sorry property
registrations and we're adding our
worklet for our paint module or paint
worklet and then on the right is all the
JavaScript I need to turn that template
into a reusable web component I extend
the HTML element I grab the content of
that template and attach it to the
shadow DOM and then under custom
elements I define a rounded tab using
that class it's six lines of JavaScript
it's not so terribly hard to do and in
the end we get this what we just saw
tabs tabs tabs but because we've
encapsulated it we can start to do
things like make everything more round
or even more round and we get those nice
rounded transitions from those tabs
dynamically through this CSS control
through our CSS we can even do things
like change the tab position so if we
look at our first tab this is on the
left we could say instead we want it on
the right and our rounded corner moves
to the other end or the middle and now
it's on both go back to left and because
we're using paint which can read in
regular properties I can change the
background of this tab to something like
purple and it will change what I've
painted as well no extra elements no
extra loading of anything this one paint
worklet is able to do all of that with
standard CSS backing it up now the final
thing we're going to talk about is the
layout API and the layout API is a
little bit heavy and it's super
experimental but it's kind of cool so
I'm gonna show it to you anyway the
paint API lets you play Tetris with your
web apps it literally lets you make your
own display properties lets you do
things like polyfill it awesome new
layouts back that you like
or because everyone likes a good masonry
layout you can write one without the
performance hit of running a bunch of
JavaScript on the main thread
now this specs a little bit complicated
so I'm gonna walk you through how the
spec thinks about layout which actually
can help you understand how browsers
think about layout layout starts with a
box a box is either an element or it is
a pseudo element the layout algorithm
for that box is something called the
current layout the boxes direct parent
is the parent of the layout algorithm
for the box's direct parent is the
parent layout the parent layout has
layout constraints those layout
constraints is the available room inside
of the parent for the box to be laid out
in the parent layout also has layout
edges these are your box model edges
padding scrollbar and borders current
layout has a child layout which is the
layout algorithm of layout child as if
it wasn't visible with display:none I
didn't name these things I'm sorry
they're named confusingly bring it up in
the spec now layout child can't really
do anything but what it can do is it can
generate a layout fragment and layout
fragments are interesting layout
fragments have an in-line size and a
block size this goes back to the
abstract sizing stuff that we talked
about all right that I think was
mentioned earlier so in line sizing and
block sizing this is stuff we can't
change we can't actually change the size
of elements when we go to lay them out
but we can change their inline offset
and block offset that's how we actually
position stuff around cool with that out
of the way let's take a look at layout
we've got input properties input
properties are actually things that go
on the parent layout so
layout API layout worklets they start
from the parent layout down as opposed
to the current layout up so input
properties these are things like your
grid template columns on display grid
would be input properties child input
properties or properties you want to
read in from the children of that layout
so this would be
like grid columns and then there are a
couple layout options there are two
functions that get called as part of
this one is intrinsic sizing or
intrinsic size which will figure out how
much room a block should take up and
layout which is the actual function that
we do our layout in now the internal
some intrinsic sizing are really complex
so we're not going to cover them the
easiest way to think about it is what
you're trying to figure out here is
given an unlimited amount of space how
big can we make a box so there's not a
lot of unused space and then also how
small can we make that box without
having any of the content overflow and
once we figure out how big it can
possibly be and how small it can
possibly be then we return that and the
browser figures out where it goes in
between those two things but the layout
function that's pretty easy to
understand the first thing we need to do
is we need to figure out what the total
size is that we can lay out our children
in so that's our inline size - our edge
inline and our block size - our block in
line bundle that up as an object and
then we loop through each one of the
children and generate a fragment based
on that constraint size this is us
generating layout constraints from there
we start actually laying stuff out we
get the block offset started at where
our edges start and then just loop over
everything we make it's block offset
whatever the block offset is we Center
it and then we add to the block offset
so we have an item go right one
underneath each other and finally add
block edges back in and we return our
children and this new block sizing and
we get something that looks like this
again not super duper terribly cool is
just a whole bunch of boxes centered on
one on top of another
but with this as our building block we
can do some really cool things like
build a layout that puts everything in a
circle puts everything in a circle in 40
lines of JavaScript for the worklet
with no external dependencies at render
engine speeds with as many elements as
you want that's 12 that's 18 up remind
me later I had disable notifications I'm
glad that popped up so yeah as many
elements as we want and we can just kind
of keep on going but wait there's more a
[Applause]
masonry layout cuz everyone likes
masonry this masonry layout is literally
45 lines of JavaScript with no
dependencies at render engine speeds you
can see it goes across one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven it's packing it all in there if I
go to my CSS if I want columns let's say
I want five columns now it's slow
because the images are reloading every
time but I have a masonry layout with
almost no overhead and I can make it
with no padding in between now I've got
this nice tight dense grid and that's
that something everyone loves but I've
got one more thing for you yeah you can
clap for masonry layout
I've got one less thing how do we use
this in our design systems well make
sure you layout we know how we use cuz
we can lay out cards forever now but how
about this this is a demo that kind of
uses everything that we've shown
transitioning custom properties typed om
custom paint worklet and that circular
layout that I just showed you to create
an animated circular navigation or dial
pad navigation without any JavaScript
for any of the animation all powered by
CSS now the animation is gonna be a
little bit choppy because something
happened in Chrome Canary and it got a
little bit choppy since I last gave this
but it looks pretty cool
I think right
now it's not as cool and I do that but
if I do that again yeah so the paint
worklet is animating an offset the
offset property and that's strong that
arc and it's animating it based on our
transition now we can do some cool
things with this because it's all CSS if
we do padding of 0 that'll stay the same
but when I close it everything shrinks
back in right now if I go really crazy
I'll set for 95 135
and now again this is 15 maybe lines of
JavaScript for the paint worklet it's 40
lines of JavaScript for the circle
layout worklet and then everything else
is just CSS and transitions because the
browser knows now knows what to do and
we're extending CSS through javascript
and you know what I think that's awesome
because with Houdini the future of our
design systems and our styling is really
bright and we all really need to party
for that because we get to add magic to
our design systems thank you all very
much
so again that's the link to the talks
here's a bunch of other good resources
Houdini glitch day is an interactive
introduction to Houdini that you can
play with your going to need Chrome
Canary with experimental Flags on and
yeah the source code for this talk is
available too if you want to dig into
all these demos thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]